Louis est élève en première année de BTS
aménagement il est intéressé pour
intégrer l'École nationale supérieure du
paysage de Versailles je vois qu'il y a
des très belles maquettes belles choses
qui ont été
faites après c'est assez sympa c'est un
moyen de rencontrer pas mal de personnes
et d' savoir plus sur cette formation
une journée portes ouvertes pour savoir
tout sur cette école qui recrute au
niveau bac+ 2 et forme au métier du
paysage chaque année 130 diplômés du
paysage passent par Versailles dont 60
paysagiste des PLG nous sommes une école
de conception donc en fait nous avons un
enseignement qui se fait beaucoup en
atelier à la table comme vous pouvez le
voir avec les maquettes les dessins et
cetera donc on trouve intéressant de
montrer ça à nos visiteurs parce qu'au
fond ce n'est pas un enseignement
académique les futurs étudiants ont pu
rencontrer les enseignants visiter le
Potager du Roi site emblématique de leur
formation et surtout en savoir plus sur
la préparation au concours dont les
inscriptions sont closes au 22 février
pour l' dire vraiment à quoi ils doivent
s'attendre ce qu'on fait tout le long de
l'année et leur donner des conseils pour
le concours l'école de versaill
disposent également d'une antenne à
Marseille plus spécialisé dans le
paysage méditerranéen une autre journée
portes ouvertes est organisé samedi 16
février